this is the other thing going on in New
York migrants accused of trashing the
luxury taxpayer-funded hotel that New
York is using for them to stay in a
staffer there finally couldn't take it
anymore so he blew the whistle he says
it's total chaos in these hotels that
the migrants are drinking all day
getting into fights throwing away tons
of the daily meals that are being
provided to them mayor Eric Adams is not
having it watch us
we're going to provide food for people
people may have a different uh cultural
tastes for certain foods we can't do
that we can only provide nutrition food
for people
I I mean you just can't make this up
I mean it's unbelievable what is
happening in these hotels and while that
goes on Florida's grappling with a surge
of migrants arriving on their Shores to
Santa's taking action sending in the
National Guard because he claims that he
got no help from the president
what we're doing is working and so I
would just tell the White House not only
has the Coast Guard asked us to help but
we have no choice but to help because of
your neglect and incompetence
and while house sounding like a broken
record while attacking the governor the
White House watched this
Governor DeSantis has made a mockery of
uh of the system and and he has
consistently and constantly as many of
you have reported uh has done political
stunts has not helped to address the
issue but has instead decided to put the
lives of migrants who are coming here
for a better life at risk and that's
what we have seen from this Governor
so Geraldo let me start with you I
wonder why when I'm reading this story
right I'm thinking about lazarus's poem
on the Statue of Liberty right give me
your tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free right and I'm
thinking there's a little tear coming
down the Statue of Liberty says when she
hears that the food is not exactly what
they would like and there is Mayhem
going on in these hotels where people
are also according to this whistleblower
having sex in the hallways getting into
fights domestic abuse is taking place
what is going on
you're asking me to uh
to vouch for the uh for the chaos in the
hotel the row okay I'm going to take I'm
going to Gaslight slightly Martha I want
to read you something from the Carnegie
Institute
quote immigrants including illegal
immigrants are less likely to be
incarcerated in prisons convicted of
crimes or arrested the native born
Americans
that means
mathematically speaking
the more undocumented immigrants you
have in a community the lower the crime
rate we'll have a safer America a safer
neighborhood I don't you know I don't
know who's in that hotel oh my God I
know that you you when you when you have
a life like that it's it's totally
distorted I don't know the story I saw
there's a I I don't know I don't
apologize for it I don't know anything
about it but I do know generally that
that is Despicable
this way
how can I I'm not going to defend
garbage drinking Corona instead of
Modelo uh you know it's uh the the
that happens that that is on the people
in the residents of that hotel I agree
and I I am an absolute 100 supporter of
Eric Adams who I've known since he was a
cop uh I I don't know the circumstances
here and I refuse to say that's about
illegal immigrants that's uh
access that's an outrageous excess
committed by whoever committed it but to
then smear the entire there are a
million there are a million undocumented
immigrants in the New York metropolitan
area you never hear about them you never
hear about them in crime stories you
never hear about them rapping hitting
people or this all right
you don't go ahead you don't I just that
Carnival let me tell you this is the
reality you know what that is not the
reality or although people come here
illegally they decide they're going to
enter our country and to answer your
question Martha it's horrible if you
want a trash hotel that costs 500 a
night 26 000 immigrants in New York City
having 500 a night hotel rooms that's
outrageous and if they don't like the
food well that's just too damn bad yeah
okay now let me get to the facts here we
don't hear about illegals because we
don't know who we are but I'll tell you
who they are but I'll tell you who we do
hear from the Latin Kings the MS-13 you
want to talk about crime how do we have
two million people coming to the United
States of America totally unvetted I
want to know who's a pedophile I want to
know who won't beat his wife I want to
know who's a cheat who drives drunk
who's a thief who's killed in another
country who's a member of MS-13 don't
give me this hogwash that these are
people they don't commit crimes we need
them for the safe for America and that's
just BS and you know it I have that
that's Carnegie Institute I don't give a
damn about carnivore I don't see how
those statistics are relevant to this
discussion you've got New York City
taxpayers you have homeless veterans on
the streets are not being given 500.
this I want to get Tyrus and Jesse in
here Tyrus what do you think well at
least four people on judge's list were
definitely at the hotel so we know that
we know that to be true I think I think
that when you look that behavior is
unacceptable but it also just goes to
show that free stuff is never good stuff
whether you're American or whatever free
stuff never although it seems like
American citizens can't get free stuff
if you're hungry like the The Narrative
we're being pushed every day is that how
they're seeking Asylum and they're
oppressed and they're running for their
lives for a fresh start in a free place
that is not the behavior you typically
see from the the people that Geraldo was
describing and the people that were
being described what we're seeing is a
free-for-all we're seeing people that
are going yay for Joe Biden like the the
flood gates have been opened the best
guess is that a million getaways are
running around that's the best guess
which means the really good ones the
really good criminals find a way to
sneak in this country so and in your
what are we doing if you were have the
ability to throw food away means you
have too much food you have too many
options you have too much free money in
your pocket my mother at some times we
had bologna sandwiches have you ever had
a bologna sandwich yes
meal cramps because that was all that
was for dinner that night when you would
give access to people who haven't earned
it and that's not just that's anyone
from any country this is what we got we
saw in the pandemic with free money we
saw bad behavior now we're seeing it
with undocumented people who are tearing
up hotels like they have another place
to go yeah Jesse here's how stupid Eric
Adams is Geraldo he built a tent city
that cost millions of dollars on an
island in the East River and they had
culturally appropriate food for them
they had tents they had popcorn machines
they had cribbage and what does he do
for although he shuts the whole thing
down that we'd paid for he shut it down
and now he's paying 500 a night hotel
rooms which they trash they're using hot
plates to cook their own food I
understand American food is not the best
but it's a fire hazard and you should
just keep it as a snack
I mean obviously if someone gives you a
free sandwich and you came here
scared you're going to get killed in El
Salvador 2 800 miles
which is a snack don't throw it away
that was your college dormitory the best
thing I could say is they're
assimilating because they're trashing
hotel rooms and having orgies in Times
Square that's the best I can say hello
though hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else